il est certain que ce soit tu te sois tu
fais de la musique niçois ya un autre
elle m'a dit qu'elle écrivait les textes
et tout ce à quoi je me suis dit c'est
est bien dû faire une petite place ce
soir viser la tu peux lâcher plus là des
tigres mais s'il vous plaît allez
choisir de venir échoue devenir une tête
devenir maîtres ou esclaves l'apprendre
ou la mettre des cités ou exécuter se
terrent envoyer paître
un jour je suis les deux puis je guette
son est bien ou du web et son été salie
l'été pop fait proprement salle
tu fais quoi là c'est quoi cette
imitation je fais semblant t'es pas
sincère cette compil je la ferai et
l'éthique qui rêve avec nous on les
décevra pas
non pas publiés mais on ne répond
il est dur avant toi tu habites à côté
d'une piscine à blogger et des
financiers avec du biac tueur tu me
poses comme ça sont masos là c'est de là
bas si tu me suis je tente des france
mardi par contre la misère sociale des
quartiers américain on a grandi là tu la
connais
du talent ait la possibilité de faire
autre chose
relève les défis c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans la vie